welcome to this video playing a son
learn son Glenn from Israel okay I'm
going for you for the 15 minute game
this always feels a bit risky to me
evening blitz it does but oh okay the
Scandinavian it's not exactly the
greatest opening no it's not bad but
it's certainly less reliable than many
others the problem is as a non regular
default player i don't really know this
opening okay i hope for c6 to get to a
pan of yeah at least i have some vague
knowledge about that so we transpose to
a carol compound off now black has been
some choice this is one move
yeah if i play on the black side a plain
night before him this weird move that
recently yeah really got discovered that
was virtually unknown couple of years
ago of course black has many mafia the
traditional main movers yeah traditional
is a detail see form after which shall
white can recapture on c4 and
temporarily sacrifice deform or you can
play d 5 which leads to sharply after
Knight e5 queen d 4 + & age six if I'm
not mistaken the solid way to play here
is I believe II six yeah it's not not
bad at all that's just continue what the
development yeah here I wonder about c5
let's let's try that not think think too
long here should be five the idea is to
get this four against three majority on
the queenside and the long run go for
before and advance of the pawns this is
also why I'm playing Bishop b5 because
it keeps an eye on the c6 night so that
it is more difficult for him to play e5
ok just Kelso here 94 is a move that I
would consider he has black to relieve
some of the pressure
yeah okay I'm glad to yeah to have
gotten the position that dumb loops some
quite yeah quite normal I mean something
that I can play just on general grounds
once in a while if I when I go when I go
eform I get caught up in some some
tricky line that I don't know okay I
didn't want to exchange this relatively
weak bishop on the 7am it should be
three is attacking the the night provoke
him to to take
okay takes be text even maybe can go be
six but this is a position where you
need to consider Bishop h7 hmm yeah well
okay I didn't want to take on d7 anyway
so maybe maybe I could have I know you
can take out c3 the Bishop d7 my idea
was Bishop besom Queenie Sam look see
one or something but it should be
certainly could have taken on c3 so when
I don't really understand is what is he
thinking about ya need to do that Bishop
h7 wasn't working anyway this is this is
interesting
yeah interesting from various reasons
one what idea can always be to take it I
mean it looks strange but like takes H
take 95 and this knight on d5 is very
strong you cannot play f6 because I take
g6 this is why taking and damaging the
pawn structure isn't is it idea at least
otherwise it looks weird to take the
night with the bishop just like that um
okay but on the other hand I don't need
to take of course and especially not at
this exact moment what I'm wondering is
some yeah what should i do instead in
the meantime like rook b1a some as a
possible
yeah he's going to play b6 this is the
the issue if he plays b6 how do i am
continue if i take 1b6 i will have weak
points on c3 at 800 k his own b6 is also
weak but i have two witnesses okay the
idea of this move is that if he goes b6
and i take two to defend c3 from the
side so let's say yeah okay I wanted to
take now but wait
i'm wondering if i take that's just for
a moment to consider that I intended
this anyway take take 95 if you take C
5d takes you 5 is this may be an
interesting position I have 56 I have c4
and the night is strong oh come on let's
let's try that it's an interesting idea
maybe he can just play bushy beard
intending f6 I'd kick it away
and yeah I this is just not clear I've
got Queen D for this was of course a
quite dynamic way to to to play this
intention SC for breaking up the center
and using the knight on d5 and the Queen
on d1 on the bishops of c-4 cannot take
because descent Hanks this is the idea
in quincy 74 always see form one looks
ahead queen default i dint see for this
was the idea just concrete concrete
claim could be good could be bad look
you always need to be cautious if you
have a relatively open position and
enter on this material distribution of y
not see form one Luke c8 I wanted to
play that this is stupid and it's still
yeah but why not one move earlier you
need to be cautious because potentially
this the bishop is just the better piece
in lots of positions so it's something
you need to consider carefully but
concrete considerations are most
important yeah here you can play but
should be aid I take d5 he can take c5
yeah not that it is too great but maybe
I'm in very good shape
what I'm wondering is what is he
thinking about
I cannot imagine any other book being
playable f6 oh no f6 looks like really
ugly okay so now take the five he will
take c5 and then I thought take andy
sixx threatening d7 maybe I don't turn
don't know it says something better
these have f 6m can probably play f6 so
take squint XD 5 Queen takes d5 rook
takes d5 d6 and f6 and this just barely
saves it yeah
this is some probably the problem
there's something else
move like 93 here protecting c5 is
probably a probably stupid okay I need
to need to take of course after Queen
takes Queen textbook text I can just
take ecigs but I think he's got f6
instead of taking only six
yeah 25 should be a yeah what's the only
move but he didn't play it maybe have
always or maybe I'm misjudging I don't
know yet this just looks like
strategically terrible the other one I
would have six I don't know I'd rather
give up give up on it happen have a
structure then then this ruin okay yeah
many ways to to play now I have this
excellent Queen on d4 one way is that
I'm the tribe 4's Luke h3 simply yeah
but I have a good square on d3 with
night f 486 coming as one idea
rookie 7
yeah I just try to decide it on the King
side it's got this very passive bishop
and maybe I can really only just play h
for now and then g4g five okay this is
their counter play I don't see it nets
let's advance all this is protecting
each other the night on protect c5 the
queen is excellent here the only thing
that's not protected is my upon so Queen
a5 we could try to to get the a pond but
even even a for I can I can just play I
want but i'm not sure that i need to
need to cover that g5 come on let's play
G fire I really don't think I need to
cover the a pond that's um it's just too
much here if he takes on g5 I even have
95 and 96 oh wait an idea member SPO
must be careful
ok he intends to go Queen to see form
hmm yeah this is an idea
ok let's let's do this first Quincy for
I can also move the Queen to e5 for
example ok if we now go squinty how I
can take f6 so maybe just here intending
96 to attack f6 finally
and also group g3 as a possible yeah i'm
not sure that i played this in a in a
very convincing way i think probably if
you analyzed with the computer it will
point out that i made some in occurrence
ok but this checklist must be winning
now really yeah this was really not
helping it takes rook takes i just get
f6 and remove the king i take f6 as well
it was it was probably not the defense
of her position anyway by now at least I
really thought that he couldn't play he
txt 520 we need to look look at this
again
yeah he just tell me I just take f6
yeah come on don't tell me you know
always afraid that they let the clock
run down and then you sit there
completely useless for four minutes yeah
now the queen is attacked and f6 is
hanging Queen f6 and she doesn't have a
queen move to protect the pawn black
resigns yeah I think here I mean it
takes d5 really looked unplayable I
thought this was the way to go and now
d6 looks nice at first but he's got f6r
looked yet this is not supported well
enough the problem so takes and now this
is obviously better for white but I
thought f6 maybe maybe I'm misjudging f6
and now the night loses its great square
here we need to go back and something I
thought you needed to play that it's a
pawn I know and the six porn but ok it's
it's near the king and i think this just
looks like better chance than the game
this is just a super one-sided position
don't you you really can debate if I if
I played in the best possible manner
this is probably not the best g4 but
it's it keeps the pressure on yeah the
computer says night before wins now
because of that and their c6 and rookies
apnea this is winning yeah I didn't see
that at all ok but this wasn't bad at
all it keeps the pressure on if he takes
him I break through the air on f6
Quincy for the squeem e5 yeah black is
just under under huge attack and my
pieces coordinate very nicely okay the
interesting game thanks for watching